Okay, everyone, move from this position
while breathing out slowly,
lowering your legs towards your head.
Doesn't it remind you of another position?
Yeah, looks just like me after the boss
walloped me with his wooden sword.
Right, that's the Plow Pose.
This pose is when you're ready
to get your pinky cut off
after screwing up real bad.
This is your pose in the driver's seat
when you give some kid the keys
to dump the car in the mountains.
This one's after taking
a bullet right in the head.
Oh, you don't have to say it anymore.
Well done, everyone!
I reckon I like this yoga thing.
Oh, really?
I haven't sweated
this much for a long time,
not since I smashed a dump truck
into the other gang's office.
What? Did he say smashing dance?
Anyway, it's good
that he enjoyed himself, isn't it?
Yeah, it was way more fun than I thought…
Oh, Tatsu!
That's the ladies' room!
Oh, Tatsu…
LEAN
BAM
What? Are you okay, Tatsu?
Boss Lady…
"Boss Lady"?
I'm prepared!
Tie me up and bury me in the mountain
or dump me in the sea. Whatever you like!
Now!
That looks like a yoga pose.